- Un moment solennel.
Kwibuka veut dire :
Pour se souvenir, ne pas oublier
les centaines de milliers deille
victimes d'un massacre inhumain.
C'est la première fois qu'un
premier ministre canadien visite
le mémorial du génocide du
Rwanda. Une marque de respect
pour une tragédie du passé.
Dans un voyage qui met l'accent
sur les préoccupations urgentes
d'un conflit en cours.
Pendant qu'au Commonwealth,
on discute des effets de la
crise alimentaire sur les pays
en développement, la Russie
a bombardé deux terminaux
à grain en Ukraine.
La Russie prend le continent
africain en otage, dit la
ministre. Les actions illégales
de Vladimir Poutine réduisentl's
essentielles.
FRÉDÉRIC MÉRAND Dép. science
politique Université de Montréal
- Cette crise alimentaire dans
les pays occidentaux, elle ne se
traduit que par un peu
d'inflation. Mais pour certains
pays, au Moyen-Orient ou en
Afrique subsaharienne, ça peut
se traduire par la famine.
- Devant l'urgence d'agir,
le Canada souhaite apporter
sa contribution.
- On annonce aujourd'hui
un 250 millions $ additionnels
pour contrer la crise
alimentaire mondiale. On sait
qu'il reste encore plus à faire,
- L'arge- L'arge- L'arge- L'arge
alimentaire mondial, afin
d'alléger le fardeau de la
famine, mais aussi pour nourrir
le dialogue diplomatique avec
l'Afrique.
BENOIT HARDY, prof. auxiliaire
Campus de Temple University
- La Russie, depuis plusieurs
années, par exempl
a quand même certains
investissements en Afrique,
a fait des efforts pour
redoubler sa présence, pour
augmenter sa présence en
Afrique,Orient
également.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU
premier ministre du Canada
- Il y a une crise alimentaire
mondiale à cause non seulement
asion de l'Ukraine par
la Russie, mais le bombardement
récent de la Russie contre du
grain en Ukraine, qui servirait
très bien à nourrir des gens
partout dans le monde.
- Justin- Justin- Justin- Justit
partagé un moment avec
le président du Rwanda,
Paul Kagamé, mais une rencontre
en privé qui était prévue
aujourd'hui a été remportée dans
les prochains jours, avec un
président qui est souvent accusé
d'emprisonner les dissidents
et ses adversaires politiques.
- Quand je vais  m'asseoir a
le président Kagamé demain,
je vais souligner, comme je
souligne toujours, les endroits
où on a plus de travail à faire.
- Une contradiction apparente,
qui illustre bien les défis qui
attendent Justin Trudeau
au Commonwealth.
L'Occident et le Canada essaient
er certains de ces pays
à la cause ukrainienne, pendant
que ces mêmes pays ont plutôt
les yeux rivés sur la Russie.
Ici Christian Noël,
Radio-Canada, Kig